il préfère un retour sur l'actualité
d'hier soir cela se passait sur tf1 à
l'antenne l'émission droit de réponse
michel polac dirige les débats s'il vous
plaît ce sens que deux minutes
elle a dit que j'ai dès que je me suis
dégonflé à strasbourg tiède absolue de
demandes latella sion car j'ai mis les
parents voilà j'avais le bras comme ça
monsieur jean françois kahn et là on a
la preuve
nous allons voyons alors passé
nous allons passer un peu de musique
cary grant franchement elle est un petit
peu de silence de boulleret n'aurait
coûté ombre bascharage 5
alain dumouch comme ci n'est que comédie
siege iii certaines valeurs liberté
c'est une valeur et je bats les c
comprend divers des schleck toujours à
sa place et convainc jamais à l'ouvert
de hollande où les damnés de la terre
on a le droit de jacques t on vous
emmerde et on emmerde jamais en emmerde
bord de mer minutes alors qu'ils
essayent de vous renvoyer le sujet d'une
mouche kim s'il vous plaît